Axios is reporting that Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi of course a Democrat
from California is announcing that the
House of Representatives is this week
going to quote introduce and vote on a
War Powers Resolution to limit President
Donald Trump's military actions
regarding Iran now of course if the
President does not seek approval if the
president ignores what they are supposed
to do then it's unclear how much this
will actually limit the president's
ability to do whatever he wants but
needless to say Nancy Pelosi said in her
letter quote last week the Trump
administration conducted a provocative
and disproportionate military airstrike
targeting high-level mil Iranian
military officials this action
endangered our servicemembers diplomats
and others by risking a serious
escalation of tensions with Iran in the
Senate senator Tim Kaine from Virginia
also a Democrat introduced a similar War
Powers Resolution now you may have
missed this but Donald Trump did file a
War Powers Resolution regarding Iran
it's super odd and it only raised even
more questions Nancy Pelosi responded by
saying this classified War Powers Act
notification delivered to Congress
raises more questions than it answers
this document prompts serious and urgent
questions about the timing manner and
justification of the administration's
decision to engage in hostilities
against Iran
the highly unusual decision to classify
this document in its entirety compounds
our many concerns and suggests that the
Congress and the American people are
being left in the dark about our
national security
can you imagine he says under Obama
Trump does you need congressional
authorization to do this type of thing
then he just does it files a War Powers
Resolution but immediately classifies it
so nobody has any idea what's actually
in it but then pretends like he's doing
everything on the up-and-up so as far as
the War Powers Resolution that Nancy
Pelosi is introducing in the house and
Tim Kaine is introducing in the Senate
anybody voting no on this should be held
to account and have to give an actual
explanation for why
they are voting no of course every
Democrat should vote YES on this
Republicans who say they believe in the
rule of law Republicans who say they
believe in the Constitution Republicans
who say that checks and balances and
separation of powers matter should all
be voting yes as well but I would not
necessarily expect them to do that if
you needed any more evidence that Donald
Trump has no idea how any of this stuff
works and just how out of control he is
look at what Donald Trump tweeted
yesterday he tweeted that his tweets
serve as notifications to Congress
look at how insane this is Trump
tweeting quote these media posts and he
capitalizes the EM and media and the
peon posts and maybe he believes that
that makes it official in some way these
media posts will serve as notification
to the United States Congress that
should Iran strike any US person or
target the United States will quickly
and fully strike back and perhaps in a
disproportionate manner such legal
notice is not required but is given that
nevertheless that's not how Twitter
works tweeting stuff from the bathroom
on your phone our does not a do that
does not qualify as legal notice it's
not how Twitter works it's not how the
presidency works and what we have if we
step back is an impeached president
threatening war crimes on Twitter like I
told you yesterday and using Twitter as
a notification tool I guess to Congress
about military action if we don't take
the country back from this law breaking
insanity what happens next
I'm all of a sudden becoming right-wing
in my opinion of executive power and the
power of the office of the presidency I
got a call a couple of weeks ago from a
viewers saying hey David are you a
right-winger on anything and I really
couldn't think of anything
maybe I am starting to be a small
government conservative in the sense
that the Trump administration is
exposing that the presidency has too
much unchecked power we've seen
unchecked power used before in to some
degree we've seen Barack Obama with the
drones we've seen George W Bush like
we've talked about this before but
generally speaking the left is not
particularly keen
stripping more and more power from the
office of the presidency maybe my mind
is being changed because I'm seeing what
Donald Trump is doing Trump's antics
Trump's belligerents Trump's ignorance
show exactly why a single person and one
office the office of the presidency
should not be allowed to hold this much
power but really what it comes down to
is the lack of effectiveness and
efficacy of the checks and balances when
we go back to the founding fathers and
the ways that they structure checks and
balances they clearly never imagined
that you would have a president like
Donald Trump that would just flout those
norms and laws and framework and it
seems as though our elected officials
are either unable or unwilling our
justice system is unable or unwilling
probably a combination of both to
actually employ those checks and
balances in a way that limits what
Donald Trump is able to do at the same
time in a sense Trump doesn't have that
much power because they could remove him
tomorrow if the entire Republican Party
hadn't decided to let him do whatever he
wants 20 Republicans is all it would
take in the Senate during the
impeachment trial to remove Donald Trump
14 members of the cabinet 13 plus Mike
Pence or is it 14 plus Mike Pence could
remove Donald Trump under the 25th
amendment but they don't and that makes
him effectively Omni omnipotent
endlessly powerful it is a dystopian
nightmare we'll talk a little bit more
later about the 14 Republicans or the 20
Republicans in the meantime what do you
think is ultimately going to happen in
Iran we are talking about this on a
variety of our platforms let me know via
tweet at D Pakman what do you believe
ultimately will happen in Iran we'll
take a quick break and be back after
this one of our sponsors is privacy calm
they're giving you $5 when you sign up
for their completely free service at
privacy calm slash Pakman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm / Pakman